[Music]
one of the most talked-about movies at
this year's Sundance Film Festival was
band-aid the romantic comedy features
CBS's life in pieces star Zoe
lister-jones and actor Adam pally as a
couple who can't stop fighting in a
last-ditch effort to save their marriage
they turn disputes into songs and start
a band here's a clip
top top fights all time okay dishes as
big obviously is available you seem to
have like a general uh uh a problem with
like my looming yeah for sure that's
spot-on yes yeah I feel like blooming in
dishes can kind of go together so maybe
just like a cleanliness thing okay um I
I want to point any fingers here but I
think you can be a little judgmental
okay okay sure
I can see that I will see you're
judgmental and I will raise you a you
being lazy okay you're uptight you're
distracted sure along with her starring
role in the film Zoe lister-jones is
also band-aids writer director and
producer Zoe and co-star Adam pally join
us this morning good morning good
morning I before we even get to the
three hats that you wore is it true that
you met each other at a party and you
just knew he would be the right person
to play your husband um we did meet at a
party I mean I had I had admired Adams
work from afar for many years but we did
meet at a party and and we were like
he's somehow hurt we were talking about
how I didn't really drink and then like
an hour later he brought me a glass of
water and clearly chivalry is dead cuz
that was like it enough for me to be
like you want to work with me um he
might bring water on the set yeah all I
need is to be hydrated apart yeah if it
was that easy and the rest of my career
I'd be Matt Damon
so we talked about how this this film
came back because I was I was very
interested in sort of reading your
statement about where this all grew from
and the fact that that in relationships
among all your friends you see this sort
of common thread that you wanted to tug
at yeah I mean I think every couple
fights but so few couples are willing to
share those personal interests ease of
their relationships even with their
closest friends because there's a lot of
shame and judgment and and when I
started to talk to my friends about what
they were fighting about it it sort of
came to my attention that we're all
fighting about the same nonsense
generally I think there's a lot of
relief in in knowing the universality of
all of the squabbles that we face and
Adam could you then be able to sort of
pull from your own marriage and put put
things in there and go off-script yeah
well um you didn't need to go up script
that much because a script was so tight
and and we were mostly on booked but uh
I definitely you're definitely able to
pull from your own relationship if
you've been married then you've fought
about dumb stuff and not dumb stuff so
maybe not written a song about it
yeah maybe not written a song about it
although I have written a bunch of
graffiti about my wife and yeah yeah I
have a tag for my wife to Jewish to
complain I'm a long time that's
impossible I need a lot of wall space I
need a lot of wall and I ended several
cans can't just do one can I make up for
her lack of complaining yeah this is the
first time you've worn all three hats
director actor writer what was that like
it was amazing it actually exceeded all
of my expectations it was obviously
there are many challenges that come with
it but um but I was working with such
amazing people and had this incredible
crew and um and it was just a lot of fun
actually
did you actually play the instruments
when we did yeah we play all of the
music live in the
you've both been in bands before yep
yeah and I wouldn't yeah high school
bands there's notes mmm not really no
well I mean like I guess it counts I
mean my bands played in front of the
side of a garage door that was like our
biggest audience and garage band yeah
Garage Band I just remember here your
high school band names
I know Adams high school band my my my
first high school bands name was pure
like water or the Aryan race or and a my
my second my second band name was inbred
Jed which was just a reason that didn't
catch on yeah it's just the most like
highschool band name to be like inbred
Jetta and then in your head you're like
that's gonna be on t-shirts everywhere
you know Saturday session in Brad Jack
yeah Zoe there was so much made also of
this being an all-female crew that you
brought into it so you write you direct
your acting in it why did you want to do
that uh well I think in my experience
both in front of the camera and behind
it
I obviously became aware of how
underrepresented women were on film and
TV crews and so I wanted to create
opportunities for women in departments
where they're rarely afforded them and
then also just like on a personal and
artistic level I just wanted to see what
it would feel like to make and how did
it feel it felt awesome it was like this
crazy utopian named Adam static yeah I
changed my life in a lot of ways it just
the getting to see that from that angle
and and getting to feel a little bit
about how hard it may be for women when
when they're not in an environment that
is so being the only man being yeah sure
yeah it was a lot of the times most of
the time yeah and it was it was great I
mean it's it's one of the things about
making this movie that I think I will
keep you know with me for a long time um
besides that sweet guitar you let him
keep it now
ah I have plans you actually you're
admiring this desk but I know you've
sort of been in this hosting role you
did the Late Late Show is it yes I
guest-hosted The Late Late Show which I
guess maybe after my Aryan race joke you
guys couldn't tell you have a clip of my
Aryan race joke no we have a clip
because that happened two seconds ago
and it did not go well keep talking
about it though um we're gonna look at
this left below sec hello America my
name is Adam pally let's all acknowledge
something together that as far as Late
Late Show guest host are concerned I'm
an odd choice not a great fit for those
of you who don't know who I am I was on
a show called happy endings and can
currently be seen on a show called the
Mindy project two critically acclaimed
and spottily viewed shows we got the
jokes there yeah what was I thinking
guest hosting that the day after I got
back from a month-long trip in Europe
with I was riding the rails like a
college student yeah it was a good look
for you it looks so weird I looked like
I look like I look like what Keane
Phoenix when he was like doing that
document yeah it looked like Joaquin
Phoenix
I look like Joaquin Phoenix having a
doctor we out of thank you so much for
joining us band-aid is currently playing
and select theaters across the country
and is available on demand